seguimos aquí desde el movistar arena en
esta fiesta del pacto histórico ya que
petrobás el presidente y francia market
su vicepresidenta y nos acompaña maría
josé pizarro que es congresista de
colombia por el pacto histórico que tal
maria jose cómo estás viviendo esta
jornada histórica
pues al principio con el nervio normal
pero ahora con una profunda emoción y
alegría
tu padre hace 32 años fue asesinado era
el líder político del m-19 se iba a
presentar a las elecciones
presidenciales con 32 años después con
gustavo petro que también perteneció al
m-19 se cierra un ciclo o hay una nueva
página de la historia colombiana si pues
mi padre firmó la paz hace 32 años fue
asesinado 45 días después
se vino la tragedia los años más duros y
más degradados de la guerra en colombia
y hoy por fin empieza a salir de nuevo
el sol en nuestro país si tienes una
camiseta que pone cambio o miedo
ha triunfado esa voluntad de cambio
respecto al miedo si brujo
definitivamente el cambio y el miedo
pues fue superado por los colombianos yo
creo que la mente se acercó al borde del
abismo y sin miedo supo saltar ahora
nosotros tenemos que hacer las cosas muy
bien para responderle a los sueños ya
las esperanzas de millones de
colombianos hablando de esas cosas que
hay que hacer bien hemos visto una
campaña las últimas semanas un tanto
polarizada es uno de los objetivos ahora
del pacto histórico en el congreso de
petro de francia market de volver a
unificar a colombia si así es llegar a
los retos de superar la polarización de
construir una nación para todos los
colombianos son de reconciliar a la
sociedad colombiana y arrancar volví
repito a escribir unas páginas nuevas
para nuestro país y esa voluntad puede
haber algún temor de no poder cumplir en
cuatro años todo así por supuesto pero
también tendremos que prepararnos
nosotros para continuar con la obra que
ha iniciado los próximos 7 años y para
terminar un mensaje que quieras dar
[Aplausos]
a los colombianos no nuestro afecte a
nuestro amor y al mundo un
agradecimiento en un inmenso porque
nunca dejaron de poner sus ojos sobre
nuestro país y hoy están abrazando con
nosotros este truco